three two one
here's the trailer for the lost city
screw you man
you led me straight to the lost city now
prepare to die there were just hundreds
of snakes in this temple just waiting
for us to show up what why aren't they
biting that guy this is ridiculous
delete delete delete
listen loretta we need you to promote
your new book on the lost city you can't
spend your life in the bathtub drinking
chardonnay with eyes
ladies and gentlemen the world's sexiest
cover model
you do know you're not dash right dash
is a character i made up that's like oh
my god
oh crap
miss sage i enjoyed your book about the
lost city and i believe you're the one
who can help me find its treasure
i have to respectfully decline i'm
afraid i must insist
unchain me that's your seatbelt
loretta sage is missing i'm going to
rescue her i just want her to think of
me as more than a cover model i'll start
living dangerously
alan what are you doing here we're here
to save you i'm certified cpr i'm
certified crossfit
this is like your book we're on the love
more and dash adventure right now let me
help you out a little bit let's go what
are you doing don't do that get out of
there this is not a romance novel
jungles eat people like us what is that
get it off give me a second i can feel
them suckers
feels like there's more holy mother of
god ah they're just sucking on my butt
like a big old jamba juice
we're so close i could actually find the
lost city
if i don't get to this island my friend
and her cover model are going to die i
am driving oh oh oh
oh
oh
the red sage getting you out of here why
are you so handsome my dad was a weather
man
hey oh she doesn't need saving in there
uh what are you doing in there
you